موجي 15
يوم حبيب قلبي ياما احنا قاعدين بنموت
بالملايين بنموت كل اللي كنت اعزهم واحبهم
كل هتهم راحوا احنا احنا مش ع احنا مش
مسلمين اسبوع الحياه والموت في
غزه شمال يانن تحت طربات دمويه اسرائيليه
قتلت البشر وسحقت الحجر ورفعت اعداد
الشهداء الى 11 500 منذ بدء
الحرب وجنوب يعج
بالناجحين عن ملاذ من
القصف
فلس
فلسطين وما بين الشمال والجنوب ممرات
مظلمه للنزوح القصري وقصص ماساويه بعضها
يروى وبعضها يطوى بموت ابطالها قبل الوصول
الى الضفه
[موسيقى]
الاخرى حاليا في مستشفى الشفا الوضع عننا
كثير كثير صعب المستشفى كامله ما حد يقدر
يطلع منها مستشفى الشفاء هو العنوان
الابرز للماسه الانسانيه هذا الاسبوع قوات
الاحتلال اقتحمت المستشفى بعد ايام من قطع
سبل الحياه عنه جثث حلله في كل جوانب
المستشفى اطفال خدج يموتون بالحاد
المتوقفه عن العمل وجرح يئنون دون علاج
وفرق طبيه تكافح لانقاذ من يمكن انقاذهم
بادوات بدائيه الاقتحام اعقب مزاعم
امريكيه باستخدام حركتي حماس والجهاد
الاسلامي المستشفى لاغراض عسكريه وبدلا من
ان يكون دخول الاسرائيليين دليلا لاثبات
هذه المزاعم فجر فضيحه من العيار الث قيل
هنا تحذف وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه فيديو
ادعت فيه العثور على اسلحه كلاشينكوف
بجانب جهاز رنين مغناطيسي ويظهر ايضا
العثور على حاسوب لمقاتلي حماس في الفيديو
نفسه ظهرت بجانب الاسلحه الصناديق نفسها
التي ادخلها الجنود قبل يوم واحد للمستشفى
اما الحاسوب فظهرت على شاشته صوره المجنده
اوري ماج داش التي زعمت اسرائيل انها اس
حررت قبل اكثر من اسبوع اعيد نشر الفيديو
بعد تعديله وحذف اللقطات التي اربكت
الاحتلال نخشى ان يتم ارتكاب مجزره اليوم
داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي الاحتلال يحرض على
مستشفى الشفاء منذ سنوات
طويله ومع نهايه الاسبوع السادس تكشفت
ارقام مفزعه عن القوه التي استخدمتها
اسرائيل في حربها على غزه وبحسب الارقام
المسجله استخدم الاحتلال 32 الف طن من
المتفجرات
و1 الف قنبله منذ بدء الحرب وكان شهر
اكتوبر الاسوا في تاريخ قتل الصحفيين
عالميا مع تسجيل استشهاد اكثر من 40 صحفيا
وعلى الجانب الاخر يبدو ان اسرائيل تدفع
ثمنا كبيرا لا يتناسب مع نتائج عملياتها
البريه ويقلل خبراء عسك ريون من اهميه
التقدم في شمال القطاع على النقيد من
الدعايه التي يروجها الاحتلال اذ ما تزال
المستوطنات ومدن الداخل المحتل تحت نيران
صواريخ
المقاومه وما تزال العمليات العسكريه
الخاطفه تستنزف القوات
الاسرائيليه الله اكبر التي خسرت اكثر من
160 اليه ودبابه اضافه الى 47 عسكريا منذ
بدء التدخل
البري واخفق حتى اليوم في اثبات اي من
ادعاءاتها بوجود اسلحه داخل الاعيان
المدنيه التي قصفتها فلجات الى اختلاق
احداث وادله مثل تقويم اسبوعي ومصعد حديدي
لكن سرعان ما تتكشف مزاعمها في عالم
افتراضي يضج بادوات كشف المحتوى المزيف ان
يقول وجدت نفقا والا هو لتعبئه الديزل
يقول وجدت متفجرات ووجدت كذا لا انت من
وضعها وانت من صورها وهي عرض سخيف من قبل
الاجهزه الاستخباريه وفي خضم الحرب
الميدانيه يتراجع اهتمام الفلسطينيين
بالحراك الدولي والاقليمي لانقاذهم من هذه
الحرب اذ لم تتاثر وتيره العدوان بالقمه
العربيه الاسلاميه التي عقدت في الحادي من
نوفمبر مناقشه العدوان الاسرائيلي ولا
يحظى قرار مجلس الامن الدولي الداعي الى
هدن انسانيه في غزه بكثير من التفاعل في
الاوساط الفلسطينيه اما على المستوى
العالمي فتعاني روايه الاسرائيليه عن
الحرب كثيرا في المجتمع الاوروبي
والامريكي وتقول صحيفه ميدل ايست مونيتر
ان اسرائيل فقدت مصداقيتها نتيجه
ادعاءاتها الكثيره واتهاماتها غير
المدعومه بادله لحركه حماس وذلك مقابل
تفوق مصداقيه فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
التي تقدم ادله لرواياتها وياتي اعتراف من
داخل اسرائيل بخساره معركه الوعي وفق
تحليل لشركه هيومنز التي يديرها مبرمجون
من الوحده
8200 الاستخباراتيه الاسرائيليه على منصتي
انستغرام وتيك توك كشف ان 6% و1 ا من المه
فقط من المستخدمين يتفاعلون مع الوسوم
المؤيده لاسرائيل مقابل
94% ينشطون في وسوم مؤيده لفلسطين ولعل
هذا يفسر كيف اثرت قضيه غزه في سياسات دول
عظمى اذ اطاحت تصريحات مثيره للجدل بوزيره
الداخليه البريطانيه سولا بفرمان بعد
وصفها مظاهرات داعمه للفلسطينيين بمظاهرات
الكراهيه وكذلك القلق المتصاعد لسفراء
فرنسيين من موقف باريس من حرب غزه اضافه
الى الدعوات المتكرره الى فتح ملف غزه في
المحاكم الدوليه ا لله يا جماعه انه الله
سقانا من ماء
المط يا جماعه الله عرف انه احنا بنعاني
ونزلنا ميه من
عيني